andré dussollier comme vous êtes un mec
honnête très très zone est un loup car
le provincial pas showbiz du tout je
vais vous faire une interview mensonge
rendez-vous swarovski génial c'est bien
fait pas bouger c'est parfait vous
voulez toujours en limousine avec les
vitres fumées
oui j'adore ça tous les matins quand
j'accompagne mes enfants à l'école
j'aime bien arriver par l'école et c'est
vrai qu'il ya des délais beaucoup c'est
vrai c'est une on aime bien voir les
acteurs au cinéma rex en limousine et
vous avez des assistants qui vous ai lu
m'bow cigarette sur les plages york où
j'en ai beaucoup je change souvent
est-ce que non mais c'est vrai c'est
difficile de supporter la vie
quotidienne un acteur donc un bien il
faut pas s'emmerder exigeait rend tous
les jours résistant un des assistants
préfère oui oui oui on vous a beaucoup
vu à saint tropez cet été avec arthur
avec carlos avec colin euros et avec
nagui est facilitée avec eux vous avez
déclaré en parlant de ses vacances là
enfin je revis et vouloir trouver quoi
c'est à dire que ils ont ils ont des
bateaux et nord ça m'a permis grâce à
eux d'éviter loana
oui j'aime beaucoup d'eau donc il ya
longtemps que j'avais arrêté l'héroïne
la cocaïne à plusieurs années non way
quelquefois away aujourd'hui fumer quand
même pétards par jour bah ça dépend pour
l'émission la whey pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup mais on voulait un parce que il
a du mal ni pourquoi tu me regardes donc
on rencontre souvent avec de jeunes
actrices dans l'est dans les soirées
mondaines à des collègues des amis dans
les premières
montrez vous acceptera très facilement
j'ai l'impression non elle est pour
mais le sais que je reviendrai toute
façon et valorise à d'accord finalement
ça se passe bien c'est un couple moderne
et je suis perdu voilà que je comprends
pas c'est cette passion des clubs
échangistes chèvrerie
je ne peux pas aller dans un club
échangiste on vous voir mais comme l'a
dit titoff la dernière fois ouais c'est
pour rencontrer les animateurs télé
papier
les officiers de renvoi du véron dans un
style
très
youpi